The police are investigating a
deadly accident in the northeast of the valley,
which is greeted by Cristian Cásseres with
his Spanish ginseng briefing.
The accident happened in the streets near
the government and Pecos. The police say that
a car collided with a truck, the
driver of that  car fled but was
arrested shortly after police
suspected driving under the influence
as a factor in this accident
gasoline prices do not seem to let up
and legislators fear
price gouging for this reason
nevada congresswoman tina tyrese together
with state attorney general  Well,
they have launched an operation to
monitor gas stations that seek to
take advantage of consumers in the
state. The public is asked that if they
believe that a business is
changing prices illegally, they can
submit a complaint, visit
disney.com in the section on  Spanish for
more details a local woman is
pleading with the public for
help  to locate his 8-
month-old pet which was stolen from his home in the
southeast of the valley the security video
as you can see there from his home
captured the moment that a suspect manages to
open the door of his house moments
later he leaves with the dog  The owner of the
audio y Ramírez mascot is
offering a reward of two thousand
dollars for the return of her mascot
Ortiz. Any information is asked
to call the phone number there
on your screen: 70 23 85 55 55 and
prepare for the return  from the cold the
maximum for Thursday in the 50 degrees
the temperatures will drop tomorrow but it
will only be for a short time as you
can see the temperatures
will rise again on Friday and climbing
up to 80 degrees for the
weekend I am cristian cásseres with your
brief informative  ignition spanish
good day